so are these still soup dumplings since
we have no soup Oh Amanda Oh Amanda
you're gonna love this
I'm Jasmine and today we're swapping
dumplings I'm half Taiwanese half Korean
so I have had a lot of different
dumplings so I've had gilze soup
dumplings pot stickers kimchi dumplings
just a whole variety of dumplings my
favorite are soup dumplings they are to
die for
I like to make the dumplings with my
family I throw dumpling parties it's
just a lot of dumplings in my life you
can pre make them throw them in the
freezer on a rainy day you have nothing
to eat you just boil some fry them do
whatever you want they're delicious in
every form you can make them into a soup
that's great I've never had pierogies
but Amanda looks so nice and so do the
pierogi so I'm excited to try them do I
think it'll beats neshama Bozz I don't
know events my name is Amanda these are
pierogies but we're having a dumpling
competition and everyone has their own
version of dumplings so this is my
country's my family is from Poland
my mom and dad mother and everyone
migrated here so I've always had
pierogies they're like our big popular
thing to have on Christmas you can also
have lots a different version of
pierogies but they're the same simple
setup but it's mostly the filling no
changes so you can have my favorite
which is potato and cheese or there is
meat ones there's one sauerkraut you can
have fruit flavored or fruit filled ones
and you can do the same thing as the
dumplings you can put them in the
freezer when you're ready pop them out
boil them or fry them up and have them
on a rainy day or a warm day and just
enjoy but any topping you want it salts
or creamer I've never had soup dumplings
I've never I think the closest thing I
ever had are like pot stickers but I
won't tell you they're probably at some
chain and probably not good enough so
I'm excited to try them traditionally
you can dip these in black vinegar and
eat it with ginger a lot of people like
to also add soy sauce and chili oil it's
really all up to your own flavor palette
which makes this really great to eat it
I like to take a bite of the dumpling
drink the soup dip it into the sauce and
then eat it you
also take a bite pour the soup out into
your spoon drink it
dip it than eat the rest or actually one
thing I really like to do is when it's
scalding hot I like to put the whole
thing in my mouth
people do not recommend that but I just
think it's so good and just like Nelson
- your mouth oh it's just like it just
melts in your tongue and like oh it's so
good
so are these still soup dumplings since
we have no soup om hand Oh Amanda you're
gonna love this and the soup is in these
ah yeah it's so good I'm scared of like
the side like little sauces and stuff
I'll guide you okay yeah the Polish
culture is not like well-known for all
our spices mm-hmm so like I feel like I
would probably love like a simple plain
soup dumpling that's what's so great
about these you don't need the dipping
sauce for this to still taste like
amazing I'm excited it's very good
oh I have to give you like everything I
hate hold that's why it was like I was
like should we just swapped chairs
do you like soy sauce I like soy sauce
okay do you like you like spice
no okay do you like vinegar no okay
ginger no oh cool the intern that's
probably so mad at me right now like try
it I can make you like my perfect sauce
- okay yeah let's do that - okay I like
to go heavy with the vinegar so I'm just
gonna like let you try this okay what
about me what do I need to know just
plop it in your mouth okay I think we
have two different flavors there we have
potato and cheese which is my favorite
and then we have mushroom and sauerkraut
I'm like not a good Polish person I
guess cuz I don't like sauerkraut and so
many people do so if you like sauerkraut
you'll probably like it my best friend
loves it when I go home I always go to
this polish deli and I buy like 12 dozen
pierogies around Christmastime I'm like
the pierogi like Christmas fairy
everyone's house that I go to I drop off
pierogies and we like make them
throughout the day you're supposed to
just put them on the pan and fry them up
with a little butter and onions if you
don't like onions you don't have to but
yep they're really yummy just slice them
in half or I don't I think there's a
really big so that might be challenging
to pop in your mouth no sorry sorry you
can do that it smells good smells like
potatoes that's the that's the move I
think mmm it's definitely like a comfort
food
you're not going to be eating that if
you want to be really healthy mm-hmm
it's potato it's cheese you can also
have sweet cheese ones which are
delicious or like a more saltier type of
cheese this is interesting it's good
when you say comfort food that's that's
not what comes to mind immediately yeah
I don't know but there's also like not
that hot right right you come over to my
house I will make you some fresh off the
pan and they're so yummy you can put
bacon little bacon bits on there like a
pancetta almost mm-hmm it's all about
the elements for this one the potato and
cheese I find it a little redundant
because it feels like I'm almost just
chewing into cook dough into uncooked
dough but I can try the mushroom one Oh
a lot better there are so many different
flavors you go to any like Polish deli
and the whole refrigerator will be
filled with different ones so it's
really just whatever you like I like it
it's good but I don't think it tops soup
dumplings for me how long does it take
to make these I mean I would just like
plan on taking an hour to two hours of
your day yeah same this will take hours
as well I'm gonna try one alone first
with nothing else I am ill-prepared for
like a soup to come out of this well try
it oh it's so good so good right yeah I
don't need to add anything to this I
want you to try like taking a little
bite of the dough and then Andrew with
the soup and then dip it into the sauce
that eat it I'll guide you okay so bite
into it a very small bite just the dough
and then don't turn it down because the
soup will fall out no I work and now
turn it so that you can drink the soup
mm-hmm and now dip it into the sauce
this one odo soup is full yeah sorry and
then now eat it it's still delicious
it's so yummy I don't think I need a lot
of that moths but I think it's so good
it's so good and there's different kinds
just like pierogies you can put
different fillings in there mm-hmm
you can make your own sauce and this
one's pork this one is pork what's your
favorite filling pork it's really good
yes I just really thought I would have a
bowl of soup I had no idea it usually
comes in the
basket - so it's like steamed in a
bamboo basket uh-huh and then they uncap
it at your table and the steam just
marinates your face yeah it's great for
facials
and I think like if you really want to
get the toxins out I imagine you smell
real nice like dinner and you smell like
a snack that's what everyone wants the
one thing you'll get ripped apart for is
biting it dumping out the soup like a
monster and then eating it that's just
wasted I'm gonna try it like this I'm
sure it's gonna be great I wish you had
more pierogies that you could try
different flavors but mm-hmm still good
mm-hmm soy sauce is delicious mm-hmm it
doesn't need it doesn't need it I'm
going to avoid the sauerkraut once Salim
balls are soup dumpling it made it's
like global presence and it was like
internationally made famous by Dean Tai
Fung which is based in Taiwan it's a
restaurant chain it's amazing it's
delicious you can watch them make the
shamah balls pin I love it and it has my
heart
oh also Shaolin bowed literally
translates to little basket bun that's
so cute so cute so cute look at this
method see I needed to see it first
mmm which ones which maybe you can cut
in half yeah I will nope there you go
there's some potato and cheese they need
to be hotter which we've discussed you
guys also got onions on these and I hate
onions no but this is comfort food this
is home this is Poland this is going
home for Christmas so today I got to try
pierogies which were really good I feel
like they were a little redundant with
the potato and cheese wrapped in dough
but overall the flavor was still very
pleasant I fancied it but I fancy soup
dumplings more Pro E's are always home
that I mean for me like I said we have
so many options it's just about how you
prepare them and they kind of have to be
like fresh off the pan that's the best
way if they sit for too long if they get
cold it's not the best version holy
fries are amazing I love them but today
I don't know I think I might have to
give it to the dumplings I don't want to
make my people upset like there
I love pierogies they're amazing Jesus
or the
oh thank you we're not even gonna fight
about it oh my god I was gonna eat that
[Music]